you know the game was so popular i think
with viewers because of its rawness and
authenticity
of the characters he's not mine is he
no this was one show that
showed so many different facets of women
meaning you had melanie barnett who was
my character
who was a student
going to medical school and she was
in love with this football player
so it had it had a romance right
and this was something that was
relatable
to a lot of young um
you know black girls out there it also
showed tasha mack who was this strong
confident who was played by wendy raquel
robinson who was incredible
who was a strong confident successful
black woman and then you had kelly pitts
right who was married to a black
football player
what i loved about the show and i think
what resonated
with a lot of fans was it was a show
about
flawed women women who weren't perfect
women who had goals who had aspirations
and
who were you know wanting to be
and feeling secure in their love life
and wanting to have a family wanting to
have a relationship
and so there weren't a lot of
characters or images like that on
television right
you tend to see the thing that i feel
like we need to continue to work towards
is seeing african-american characters in
a positive light
not always in some sort of drama
this was a show that reflected
true characters and people that
you know or characters that people can
relate to and i think that's
just what was so awesome about the show
and then
there was you know a beautiful love
story with uh melanie
and darwin and her just being there for
for her man you know and supporting him
and and wanting the best in life
[Music]
you